Pixar is moving Onward, and critics are pretty
much on board.
Reviews are coming in for Pixar's latest offering,
and the general consensus is that while it
may not be quite on par with some of the studio's
classics, it still packs plenty of laughs,
charm, and eye-popping animation.
Onward tells the story of two elven brothers
who inhabit a once-magical world that seems
to have lost some of its luster.
Together, they embark upon an epic quest to
discover if there is any magic left in the
world, magic which might help them resurrect
their departed dad long enough for them to
give him a proper goodbye.
The flick is directed by Dan Scanlon from
a screenplay he co-wrote with Jason Headley
and Keith Bunin.
Marvel Cinematic Universe alumni Tom Holland
stars as Ian Lightfoot, while Chris Pratt
lends his voice to Barley Lightfoot.
Among the supporting cast are Julia Louis-Dreyfus,
Octavia Spencer, Mel Rodriguez, Ali Wong,
and Tracey Ullman, whose Fox variety show
introduced the world to The Simpsons in 1987.
Even the flicks that don't live up to the
greatest entries in Pixar's catalog are still
going to be a cut above your average animated
fare, and the majority of critics felt that
Onward was a perfectly fine animated comedy
with the requisite amount of heartstring-tugging.
Also, obviously, it looks spectacular; nobody
ever accused Pixar of cutting corners when
it comes to animation.
Kristy Puchko of IGN wrote:
"...Scanlon has crafted an adventure that
gleefully flies high with its fantasy elements,
yet never loses touch with its grounded family
tale...
Plus, it has a sensational pace that keeps
the adventure rollicking and keeps the audience
on the edge of their seats... a terrifically
entertaining tale filled with humor, heart,
and allusions that are sure to delight fantasy
fans."
Many reviewers were a bit more reserved in
their praise, alluding to Onward's failure
to hit the storied heights of Pixar's greatest
while still acknowledging its strengths.
CBR's Cynthia Vinney said:
"Onward simply doesn't have the same emotional,
dramatic or comedic power as the best of Pixar...
[It's] a minor entry in the Pixar canon...
a perfectly pleasant way to pass the time."
Overall, though, Onward received kudos for
the performances of Holland, Pratt, and Spencer
in particular, and for hitting those familiar,
emotional notes we crave from Pixar.
Den of Geek's David Crow remarked:
"Whatever its shortcomings, Onward is still
an amusingly clever piece of family entertainment
with a tangible heart at the center of its
book of spells…
This might be Pixar on an off-day, but even
then it feels like spending quality time with
a dear loved one."
A fairly strong contingent of reviewers were
quite a bit less forgiving.
"I see you brought sustenance for our adventure!”
“No, It's garbage for the trash can."
They tended to peg Onward as half-baked, too
long, and... well, extremely weird in an off-putting
way.
Mick LaSalle of the San Francisco Chronicle
wrote:
"Onward looks great, and it has a couple of
strong scenes that are gripping and even ingenious.
But as a whole, the movie is misbegotten,
overlong and altogether unconvincing as a
story of familial love...
Long before its 114-minute running time has
elapsed, it has overstayed its welcome."
Mike Ryan of Uproxx was even less kind:
"This is a movie about two kids resurrecting
their dead dad's crotch and it's just the
WEIRDEST thing...
At one point in this movie I literally tried
to get emotional.
If I'm watching nothing I can make myself
get there.
Watching Onward, I couldn't do it.
Every time I felt even a hint of emotion,
here comes the walking crotch."
Other reviewers slapped Onward with labels
such as "undercooked," "flattened and diluted,"
and "disappointingly pedestrian."
The consensus of Onward's negative notices
was summed up nicely by Josh Spiegel of Slashfilm:
"Onward is...
OK.
The problem with Onward is that Pixar's original
films are incredible.
OK is, simply, just not good enough."
The majority of critics, though, found Onward
to be a satisfactory-if-unspectacular addition
to Pixar's catalog.
You can see for yourself whether the flick
hits your own personal mark when it drives
into theaters on March 6.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.